Salam.
>> First of all, I'm 17. So, just to say my
age. Is that okay?
>> Sure. I
>> just want to speak I just want to speak
of my beliefs. Um, I want to ask
something about something in the Bible
that you guys believe in. You believe
that Jesus is God, right? But isn't he
the son of God?
>> Yeah. Him being the son of God means
that he has the same nature as God, you
know? So, like for example, Jesus is
referred to as the son of man as well.
And cuz he's has a human nature. He's
man. So he's both. When it says he's the
son of God, that's demonstrating that he
shares the same nature as God.
>> So you're saying there's three gods.
No. Sorry. Sorry. Yeah. What?
>> One. One God. One God, three persons. So
there are three persons that are united.
God is God.
>> Three forms of God.
>> Three persons. So God is he's you you
would agree that God is unlike anything
in creation, right?
>> So in creation, we can point to things
that are like one being and one person
like like for example you and me like
you're you're one being and you're only
one person. I'm one being and only one
person, right? So there's nothing we
could point to in creation that's like
God though. God so God being completely
unique, he's one being in three persons.
So,
>> okay. But you're saying God can be a
human. A flawed human.
>> God. No, not a flawed human, but a a
perfect human.
>> No, you're saying he's a human.
>> We're all flawed as humans. Isn't that
right?
>> Not Jesus.
>> Not Jesus. But he's a human.
>> It would. He's So, like for example,
Jesus never sinned. Would you agree?
>> No. No. To be honest, I won't agree.
>> You won't you believe Jesus sin? Listen,
I am as I said I'm 17 and I don't know
much about this topic but I want to say
that every prophet sinned except
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
of course Allah because he's not a human
Allah who is talking about the prophet
he never sinned any other prophet sinned
they had like I'm not
>> can I show you a verse can I show you a
verse that says that Muhammad sinned
okay so so this verse is uh
um it's chapter Chapter Chapter 48 Surah
Alfat verse 2.
>> Okay. But can I say something before?
>> Yeah.
>> There is a lot of people in the comments
who keeps attacking me. And you aren't
you and Christianity supposed to like
respect other religions. Is that right?
You know
>> is the comments bothering you?
>> No. There's a mod of yours. He's Look at
his name.
>> What's his name?
>> Prophet. I don't understand his name.
>> Prophet Google. Is it prophet Google or
something like that?
>> I don't understand his name. I cannot
say it. I'm Arab, you know. My first
language is not English, you know.
>> Yeah. Oh, Prophet Berman.
>> Like you in Christianity supposed to
prophet Burman. Be respectful, man. You
be nice. All right. He's going to be
nice from now on.
>> And he's your m he's going to be nice
from now on. Okay. So, here's the verse.
Okay. Here's chapter 48:2 talking about
Muhammad. It says that Allah may forgive
you of your past sins and of the sins
that will follow and complete his favor
upon you and guide you to a straight
path. So it shows
>> repeat that so
>> yes
>> I can rewind.
>> Yep. So it says that Allah may forgive
you for your past sins and your future
sins and complete his favor upon you and
guide you to a straight path. Yeah,
that's true.
>> So, Muhammad sinned in the past, he
sinned after that, but Allah forgave him
for both his past and his u future sins.
So, he did send
>> give me what he sinned. Give me what he
sinned. A verse in the Quran, a verse in
the I think I don't know what they call
it in English.
>> I can give you a verse where I can give
you an example where he sinned.
>> Of course. So he sinned here in uh in
chapter 66 verse1 he made something
haram that Allah made halal and uh and
Allah corrected him on it. So it's a
>> which what's the thing I want to
understand?
>> So he um you want to know what he what
he did like what he made haram.
>> I know come on say it. Married a
9year-old.
>> No no that was that was a sin obviously
but in this in this context it's talking
about Okay. Well, in this in this
context, it's talking about uh it's
talking about when he um slept with uh
one of his sex slaves, Maria the Cop.
Yeah.
>> True. Say it again.
>> Maria the cop. You heard of Have you
heard of Maria the Cop?
>> No. What's What's the name? I don't
know. If you say it in Arabic, I will
understand. But you're not Arabic.
>> Yeah, I'm not Arab. Sorry.
>> Show me the name. Show me the name.
Like, can you type it in the chat so I
can
>> Yeah. Somebody Somebody type Maria the
cop.
>> Maria. Sorry. I'm so sorry.
>> What's funny?
>> Because that never happened. Where are
you coming with that? Wait,
>> you're saying that? That's
>> Who's Maria?
>> You don't know who Maria is?
>> How? No.
>> Are you Are are you a Sunni? Are you Are
you a Sunni Muslim?
>> Of course, there's no Shia Muslim. They
don't believe in Islam actually in
everything in Islam. So, they're not
Muslim.
>> Okay. So, this is what the verse says in
in 66:1. It says, "Oh prophet, why do
you make haram what Allah has made halal
for you, seeking the approval of your
wives and Allah is forgiving and
merciful." So we see there that that's
an example of Muhammad committing a sin.
>> Wait, what he No, repeat that again.
that like wait
>> oh prophet
>> sorry
>> oh prophet why do you make haram what
Allah has made halal for you seeking the
approval of your wives chapter 66
>> chapter 66
>> in which ayah
>> surah at tarim
>> okay can someone type it in the chat so
I can see cuz I know that I don't write
because it's impossible that would be
right actually sorry let me mute my mic
in there
>> it's okay still you there?
>> Yeah. Yeah. What's up, brother? God
bless.
>> God bless. You want to help me out with
with these uh words here for her?
>> Of course. So,
about
you know,
go ahead. I don't know what she want,
but she said, "I've never ever heard
about her."
>> She might be She might be trolling to be
honest with you. She like giggling and
stuff.
>> Listen,
>> I think so. since she bought out 9 years
old.
>> What?
>> You don't believe that Muhammad slept
with Aisha when she was nine?
>> No. No. Actually, there's a whole
explanation on this and I can translate
it into English because I know it in
Arabic. I can come up tomorrow as a
guest and tell you all about it and tell
you about this. Maria,
>> I'm down. I'm down for that. I'm down
for that.
>> And another thing And another thing I
want to say
>> cuz all the hadith say that. All the
hadith say that she was nine when he
slept with her.
>> No, no, I'm not.
>> No, no. So, are you gonna deny the
authentic book besides the Quran which
it's the second book besides the Quran
which is Bkari and Muslim. Are you going
to deny Bkari now?
>> No, I'm not denying it. I'm just saying
you're not understanding the verse.
That's why you're keep
>> We're not understanding when the verse
is saying that Muhammad entered upon
Aisha when she was 9 years old. Is that
what we're not understanding?
>> No. Because you guys reading,
>> you're understanding the verse wrong.
You're not reading everything like you
read the like the small god.
>> This is Oh my god. She said that and
give me one verse where he said I slept
with a 9year-old.
>> Okay, that's fine. Yeah, that's fine. We
could definitely do that. That's not an
issue. It's within the sunnah since you
are Sunni and you have to affirm what
says. Now again this narration is not
only within Bkari but it's even within
Sah Muslim. They both of them uh put
this chain of narration. Okay, they
authenticated it. It says that when
Muhammad married Aisha, he married her
when she was 6 years old, but he entered
upon her when she was 9 years old. That
you just said earlier that you don't
believe in. They're the ones that
believe that Aisha was 18 years old. Not
the Sunnis. All of the Sunnis agrees
that Aisha was six when Muhammad married
her, but when he entered upon her, she
was 9 years old. You can laugh all you
want, sister. You can laugh at your
religion.
>> I mean, it's up to you.
>> I'm going to come up tomorrow and I'm
going to give you all the proof you need
that I am saying the truth because
listen, I don't
if you bring the says that Ash is not 9
years old, I will give you 500 bucks in
front of everybody. So, so just to be
clear, you're saying that you're saying
that you're saying the hadith is
incorrect here when it says that Aisha
>> it says narrated Aisha the prophet
married her
show me in Arabic. Show me in Arabic.
>> My god. No. No. What's the hell? Give me
Give me the Let me Let me screenshot it.
Let me screenshot it. And 100% sure I'm
going to come up tomorrow because right
now it's too late. like for
>> but can you just tell everybody what
does it say in the Arabic just you were
actually reading it in Arabic can you
please translate to what it really says
at least
let me just read that again
go ahead
>> I don't know how to say it waitham
no so this gives you the chain of
narration then you go down and it says
what
right he married when she was 6 years
old. Then what does it say after that
mean?
What does it mean? When we say what does
that mean?
>> You know many words in Arabic does it
mean how do I explain it?
>> Come on. Come on. Come on man.
>> You understand Arabic right?
>> It say it says that he he slept with her
nine.
>> The guy I'm not talking about you. The
other guy. Can he? Yeah, of course. Of
course. I'm not a speaker, but I will
just read in Arabic front of you and I'm
from Middle East. What does it mean when
Okay.
When people get married, when in the
Middle East, Middle East people get
married, right? What do we Why do we say
the night of what? Why do we say that?
>> You You don't understand. Let me just
speak.
Yeah, I'm saying
I totally understand that there's
different meanings when it comes to the
words, but it depends on the context.
Correct. When we say right, we're
talking about that when the man and a
woman gets together and you know they
sleep with each other. This is why we
say now what does it say over here in
this? The point the reason why I should
be saying this we're not going to we're
not
>> we're not going to we're not going to
spend years on this and playing games.
What does what what does it say? Does it
say that he slept with her or not or
>> wait show me the English translation
again? He didn't sleep with her.
>> You see how
>> he say he didn't marry her when she was
nine.
>> Can you read this?
>> And I know it.
>> Can you read it?
>> But can you read it? Intercourse.
What? That's the translation is so
wrong, man. What the hell?
>> Is it really? Can you read the Can you
read the Arabic for us?
>> Can you get it closer?
>> If I have to be honest, your Arabic is
not that great, sister. If I if I'm
being honest, I'm trying to understand
that. That's
>> the word is the word is the word is over
there.
What does it mean when someone says
>> okay and when it talks about the
marriage
>> only means no
means me entering upon you when
you know me and you getting together and
having sexual intercourse it can't be
anything else besides that come on
sister you're smarter than that
>> are you sure
>> I'm positive yes
>> now if I can do my research and I can
prove you wrong tomorrow.
>> Okay. Come back tomorrow.
>> I'm going to show you. I'm going to
prove you.
>> All right. Come back tomorrow. We'll be
ready. Okay.
>> Okay. But I want to say one last thing.
>> One last thing. No, no, no. You got to
bring it tomorrow.
>> Okay. Fine. I'll do it tomorrow.
>> All right. Take care. Have a good rest
of your day. Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. King Sil in the house. Shoua
hot. Shoua hot. Shoua. Shoua. Shoua.
Shoua hot. Shoua hot.
>> That's right.
>> Shoua. Shoua. Shoua hot. Thanks man.
Thanks.
>> Likewise, brother. God bless, man. Do
what you got to do, mate.